Razer are responsible for creating what
many people consider to be the first
ever gaming mouse they've manufactured
gaming peripherals longer than just
about anyone else and have produced some
of the most popular products in the
entire world but none of their Creations
are quite as iconic as the Death Adder
this is like the mouse man
No Frills Master Class piece of
Machinery that just feels really good to
use
it's also the best-selling gaming mouse
it's like a staple in The Gaming
Community this is nearing perfection
this this thing is nice for years the
Death Adder has been one of the most
popular head clickers in Esports no
matter what game they were playing Pros
have made history with this mouse in
their hands I have no idea he's here
this early it's cool one let's go free
oh my God
[Applause]
Razer has released several new and
upgraded death adders over the years and
it all culminated in this the DeathAdder
V3 Pro Razer claims it's lighter more
ergonomic and better than ever before
but is this new Death Adder really worth
all the hype
[Applause]
all right so before we start talking
shop about Razer I have to do the sales
department a solid and start spouting
some really nice things about Opera GX
which isn't that hard actually since it
goes fairly hard unlike a certain other
browser Opera GX lets me fine tune just
how much CPU and RAM it's allowed to use
at any given time
you were the chosen one this means that
if I'm writing and decide to pug one on
my lunch break I will not need to close
the 18 tabs I will inevitably have open
before begrudgingly queuing into another
Dallas Inferno all Opera GX also lets
you import all of your existing settings
from other browsers such as bookmarks
cookies and yes extensions which was a
huge Plus for me and made switching to
it incredibly easy I cannot live without
face at enhancer and now I don't have to
last but certainly not least Opera GX
boasts an exclusive feature that allows
you to see the latest 12 uploads of your
favorite YouTube channel so if you're
like me and terminally online
and just never ever want to leave your
house
Opera GX has got you covered alright so
unless you live under a rock chances are
you've at the very least heard of Razer
they've been around for decades
producing some of the most popular
gaming peripherals in the world and back
in 2006 they released their most iconic
product ever the Death Adder it was an
ergonomic Mouse and the first Razer
product with a 3G infrared Optical
sensor with its thousand Hertz polling
rate the Death Adder was one of the most
precise gaming mice in the industry
Razer kept upgrading the mouse year
after year but it was in 2012 that they
released what many consider to be the
most iconic iteration of their famous
product the Death Adder 2013 was
designed for competing at the highest
level razor-shaped 28 grams off the
previous version and outfitted the 2013
model with a newer more accurate 4G
sensor many Counter-Strike players in
particular quickly fell in love with
this updated model which was surprising
since by this point most of them were
already died in the wool steel series or
zowie stands you play with the
deathbedder 2013.
mouse is a Black Death Adder razor but
it wasn't just a plethora of
Counter-Strike players who swore by the
new Death Adder they were joined by a
certain Superstar mid laner from South
Korea
like even though I only have a mat on
the floor I think he's in the bed oh
Baker may be in trouble your death Mark
tries to clean it up for Ryu oh look at
the glass look at the moves back
why was that Faker LED SKT to three
World Championships while holding a
Death Adder 2013. so from the outside
looking in it sort of looked as if Razer
had created the perfect gaming mouse
this ubiquitous Masterpiece that could
be used by any competitor in any esport
to great effect it's like widely
available you want to Target and you had
it you know pretty much anywhere
anywhere you would go that that thought
it would be there so yeah it's like a
staple in The Gaming Community
from tax Shooters to mobas people
everywhere were winning events using the
Death Adder over the years Razer
sharpened the DeathAdder 2013 to near
Perfection giving it a better sensor
Optical switches and reducing the weight
so much that it became one of the
lightest wired mice on the market I got
a razor DeathAdder back in 2013 because
I think I Googled top 10 Mouse gaming
mouse or whatever when I was like 12 or
whatever and then I bought that and then
I kept using death header and every time
I broke I just bought a new one because
I didn't want to switch mice and I
didn't want to go through like
researching and figure out whatever so I
just kept using that and using that and
it kept breaking I think I had like
seven different Fighters for like five
years and then like eight months ago I
just bought that fighter V2 instead of a
Death Adder when it broke and then I've
been using that that's it unfortunately
as great as the Death Adder was there's
no such thing as
perfect some Death Adder models were
Infamous for having a various scroll
wheel issues but over time it became
apparent that the biggest problem with
this mouse was that it still had a wire
so in September of 2020 Razer finally
answered everyone's prayers it's
wireless the the new wave is making your
mouth Wireless and razer's been on that
the V2 Pro had basically everything long
time Death Adder fans could hope for it
could be used wired or Wireless with
razer's new hyperspeed technology or it
could even run on Bluetooth now the
general consensus was that the V2 Pro
was a stellar Mouse so when Razer
announced that they were releasing yet
another update people wondered what else
they could be possibly looking to
improve upon it sort of felt after the
V2 like there was just nothing
substantial left to fix and we and a lot
of others wondered is the V3 Pro just
kind of a waste of money
we decided to find out Razer was kind
enough to send denial a Death Adder V3
Pro to test out for this video and
here's what he had to say about it and
now the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about alright so first off I
just want to thank Razer for sending me
this mess to test out this video is not
sponsored by Razer so everything that
I'm about to say is just my honest
opinion on the mouse now I did have a
deathouter 2013 back in the day and I
really did like that Mouse but
unfortunately my scroll wheel broke and
I pretty much jumped shipped to Logitech
from then on I was playing League of
Legends back then so I've really been
looking forward to testing out this
newer version of the Death Adder on some
FPS games I've been using the V3 Pro
with the stock skates on an extra soft
Artisan hen pad for the past three weeks
and I've pretty much loved it from the
get-go I was worried that it would take
time for me to feel comfortable with it
because I don't normally use Ergo mice
but since it's roughly the same weight
as my super light the transition was
pretty seamless the ergonomics on this
thing feel perfect to me Razer says they
worked with a bunch of Pros to help
create this new shape and here's what
they changed from the V2 they shifted
the two side buttons and the scroll
wheel up and moved the DPI switch to the
bottom of the mouse so you don't
accidentally hit it mid gunfight the
flares on the sides of the mouse aren't
as aggressive as they were on past
iterations of the Death Adder but
there's a very subtle ledge where your
ring finger sits and it makes the mouse
feel really comfortable as someone who
uses a palm grip I've never felt any
sort of discomfort while using this
mouse even during those extra long old
school RuneScape grinds the raised hump
in the middle and the improved pronation
support make all of my movements feel
more natural which has helped my aim
feel more consistent razer's New Gen 3
switches also feel great and they claim
that they're good for 90 million clicks
but most importantly they sound crisp
nice it's a crisp click
now I did experience a few mouse jumps
during my first week of testing but
unfortunately I didn't think to capture
them probably because I was molding but
apparently my buddy ethos also had the
same issue it's a nice Mouse oh the one
thing I'll say though is it's freaking
nice jumps I don't know if yours mouse
jumps I don't know if you have new bound
uh jump to scroll wheel but I've jumped
a Scoville up and it jumps this is
straight out the box luckily I haven't
had issues since my first week with the
mouse so I'm not really sure what caused
it overall I think that Razer genuinely
killed it with this mouse and it's the
little details that make it it uses USB
type c and the dongle is weighted just
right so the cable doesn't drag off your
desk it also comes with these grips for
Mouse one and two and the sides of the
mouse but I didn't get a chance to try
them just yet I'm honestly so happy with
this mouse and I think I'll probably go
buy my own once this video goes up
unfortunately I wasn't able to test out
the upgraded 4K dongle but I've been
told that it's great I am really good
friends with fresh reviews on YouTube
and I know you he loves that Mouse uh he
liked the original DeathAdder a lot so
he says that that's been widely improved
um I know the 4K dongle is also a great
addition hopefully Logitech and other
companies follow along with that you
know let me see it more implemented
um but I do like it a lot um from what
I've seen at least uh I did paint one
and I did like how it you know the mouse
felt pretty good in hand the quality was
there always the DeathAdder V3 Pro costs
150 US Dollars which may sound like a
lot but that's the price you pay for a
lot of Premium gaming Minds so if you're
in the market for a high quality medium
to large size ergonomic gaming mouse and
you should definitely consider the
DeathAdder V3 Pro it's the one mouse
that has stopped me from using my super
light and so far I love it and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about so rather than releasing
an entirely new product Razer have opted
to refine their most iconic one instead
the V3 Pro may actually be the best
Death Adder yet which is sort of crazy
consider there's like a thousand
iterations of this thing but as far as
the shape and all I like it a lot and I
actually like that these companies are
going back to their original shapes that
people loved and updating them right so
that they have you know newer components
and all that stuff some Gamers myself
included just don't really like to
change their peripherals
accustomed to something and it works
why change it but this iteration of the
Death Adder feels familiar enough that
fans of the original can pick it up and
use it and those who never had the
chance to try one back in the day can
still enjoy it for what it is now plenty
of Pros have already made the switch and
some of the ogs have even returned with
the release of the V3 Pro there's a
reason why Razer have sold 15 million
death adders in 15 years and if the
success of the V3 Pro is anything to go
by
they're not gonna be going anywhere
anytime soon
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock